you guys all four of you all are so
funny and convenient if you were to do a
competition ship which one of you guys
would win oh gosh it depends what we're
doing it wouldn't be me I honestly I'm
not good under pressure
like you've seen I've done game shows I
just filmed Ellen's game of games today
I just know and and when it comes to
like a direct talent play can you do
this this this no I don't have that I
feel like Jeff can pant he can draw he's
hilarious
Amanda's like amazing at so many
different things she is her salt like
the best
she's like just she's so funny you know
but she's so up on everything like nope
like no matter what the topic is she can
talk to you about everything I mean then
Kenan of course the genius I would think
Jeff would be like maybe they like if we
run an island or something Jeff would be
the only reason we survived okay so we
love living through you know your family
actually your kids what you guys do do
they already have their funny
personalities and which one of them are
funnier if that is I know Luna has
amazing timing she is so verbal she
obviously everybody's kids say something
you're like where did you get that or
but with us it's like how did you learn
that tone or phrasing like she phrases
things really well and and she like
holds a beat to like give the punch line
with things and it's really interesting
but yeah she's she's so funny what's the
funniest thing she's done lately oh gosh
well she's constantly debating and John
loves that cuz he talks to her like as
if he she's like just a counterpart like
I mean it's amazing okay how about let's
go into negotiations now how about okay
how many pieces of candy I say one what
do you say I say like okay three that's
a good negotiator all right what about
one
no I want to eat hmm
what about to know I mean it's
every day there's something she calls us
like every more like if I say something
say [ __ ] like god you're such a goose
where did you get that it was like it's
just everything she reads she holds on
to forever and and we always tell her to
tell us a scary story and she just like
gets up and she's like once upon a time
and it's so dramatic the readings of it
but it's I don't know anywhere just
dorky parents but we think everything's
funny does John think you're as funny as
all of us think you are my number one
fan I think he and he probably oh yeah I
don't even know if it's true but he
really is like a very big supporter tell
me this has there ever been a real
thought in your head like maybe I would
try stand-up or I'd go that route
cuz you really are funny thank you I
even when it comes to acting or anything
I think it's just really daunting which
is why I love doing something like this
because I have such an immense respect
for them the fact they get on that stage
in the first place I think is so
incredible and the Falls that goes into
that is so it's it's insane and I
personally could not do it but that's
why I appreciate it so much someone
that's good at that you know it's such a
they make it look easy when you're good
at it you make it look easy and it's
fascinating to me but you're doing
Chrissy's court so on a scale of 1 to
Judge Judy where do you fall I'm so
excited I mean I'm going to I think I'm
gonna be pretty tough not as I don't
have like the lines like her like don't
pee on my leg and tell me it's raining
like I don't have those lines but you're
gonna have some but they're gonna be
some class yes I'm so excited for the
actual line because it's just dumb
little cases like the petty stuff and
that's I that's what I think is gonna be
the funniest about it is how how like
minuscule and silly the cases are so
we're gonna have so much fun with it my
mom's a part of the show and I can't
wait
with your mom John come in maybe the
stenographer eekum oh I don't know oh he
would be yes oh my gosh he would be
incredible at that but no he's always so
middle ground with things like he he
wouldn't make a good judge but I don't
know what could he do on the show maybe
like the guy at the end that's like
interviewing them after but yeah he's
mom and I got this handled
[Music]